Singapore is truly an international city.
There are four official languages but you'll
hear dozens more
on the streets of this island city-state
Half the population is temporary, stopping
in to work or study for short stints
And that constant coming-and-going creates a vibrant
mix of cultures.
Tucked under Malaysia, Singapore was only
founded in 1965
It's now one of the richest nations in the
world and a global financial hub.
Singapore invested a whopping $1 billion in
startups and 37 thousand international companies
are based here
The first thing you need to know about Singapore is it's
not all work.
The city now claims six of the world's
best bars, plus 47 Michelin stars.
So let’s start here - at the swanky Atlas
bar
Front and centre is the colossal gin-tower,
packed with over 1000 varieties.
This art-deco bar opened last year and was
quickly rated in the world's top 20
But if you’re looking for something a little
less shouty, head over to D.Bespoke
The Ginza-style bar is regularly rated one
of the best cocktail spots in the city
it’s sleek and sumptuous interior draws
in a sharply dressed crowd
But you don’t have to spend a fortune to
enjoy the breadth of what Singapore has to
offer
The city state has three major ethnic groups
- Chinese, Malay and Indian
To have a taste of the more traditional and
colourful side of Singapore, plan a day trip
to the cultural enclaves of Chinatown, Little
India or the Arab Quarter
But if you want to eat where the chef choose
to eat - try this.
Burnt Ends is not a good option for vegetarians
It specialises in grilled meats and has become
a favourite of local and visiting chefs
Set up by two Australians this modern barbecue
restaurant is famous for its open kitchen
and super-heated coal oven
It's actually illegal to rent out private
homes in Singapore so stick to hotels
And luckily there's plenty of those
We’ve saved, what’s probably singapore’s
most famous hotel and bar for last and that’s
because you can’t get in there at the moment
Raffles Hotel is where the Singapore Sling
was invented and it's reopening in the fall
of 2018 after a massive rconstruction
finally, if you find yourself with time some
down time go see the audacious Gardens by
the Bay
Populated with giant Super Trees, these structures
are really hanging huge gardens
Total cost of the public park was $1billion
part of a push by Singapore to transform into
what they call a City in a Garden.